yeah i think the big news here isn't
just what they've done with interest
rates so come back to that in a second
this is their big opportunity to to give
their forecast for the state of the uk
uh economy and it's the first time
they've done that since the russian
invasion of ukraine and this is a really
striking very gloomy forecast they are
forecasting that the uk will face an
effective recession towards the end of
this year seeing the impact of those
energy prices feeding into families
bills and pushing down their ability to
spend
and that will cause uh a recession the
other warning for the bank is that on
top of that already in the face of that
we are going to see double digit
inflation so the first time that uk
inflation the consumer price index has
got above 10
since the early 1980s
so that combination of a recession uh
stagnant growth essentially next year
plus double-digit inflation well that is
a toxic cocktail for the uk economy and
on top of that the bank is judging that
the only way they can try to pull down
inflation which is you know that's what
they're supposed to do they're supposed
to keep it as close as possible to two
percent the rate at which prices are
going up uh the only way they can do
that is to carry on raising interest
rates so households are facing at the
same time rising energy costs you've got
the rising impact of tax costs going up
as well and then on top of that you have
interest rates from the bank of england
going up which pushes up your cost of
borrowing put it all together and you're
talking about one of the gloomiest
forecasts i can remember coming out of
the bank normally you know for the
financial crisis for covert they're
forecasting a recession that we're
already in
this time they're talking about a
recession that's coming towards the end
of this year in other words pain that is
coming we're all feeling pain at the
moment as a result of higher energy
bills but they're talking about an extra
pain that's coming up later on this year
when those bills when that starts to
feed into to our energy bills thanks to
the off com
off gen price cap and so on so it really
is quite a striking uh forecast i can't
quite remember another forecast like it
which has been quite so gloomy
looking off towards the end of next year
towards the end of this year and into
next year a recession warning for the
bank of england